.
AMERICAN EXPRESS HALFTIME
REPORT.
ERNIE JACKSON, CHUCK, SHAQ.
THE CLIPPERS --
>> THE CLIP FRERS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
>> IS THERE A POINT AT WHICH YOU
SAID, OKAY, NOW I'M GOING SAY
THEIR NAME?
>> IF THEY WIN A PLAYOFF GAME.
>> SO YOU'RE GOING TO SAY THE
WORD LAKERS FOR THE REST OF THE
SEASON.
>> THE REST OF THE SEASON.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
LOSERS.
THE NITWITS ON TNT AND ESPN, WE
TALK ABOUT THEM ALL THE TIME.
>> I FEEL LIKE A PRISON NOR IN
ALCATRAZ.
>> I FEEL YOUR PAIN.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE LOSER
ANYMORE THIS YEAR.
>> YOUR AMERICAN EXPRESS
TEAMMATES, REGGIE JACKSON, A
15-POINT FIRST HALF, AND
COVINGTON OFF THE TY LUE BENCH.
>> CAN I SAY SOMETHING?
>> YEAH, GO AHEAD.
>> REGE REGGIECY SAYS SOMETHING
INTERESTING.
ME AND KENNY TALKED ABOUT IT.
WHAT THE CLIPPERS DID AT THE
TRADE DEADLY WAS SPECTACULAR,
AND WHEN THEY GET KAWHI AND PAUL
GEORGE BACK NEXT YEAR, THEY'RE
GOING TO BE A HANDFUL FOR
ANYBODY IN THE NBA.
>> TRUE.
>> YEAH, PAUL GEORGE.
26 GAMES, HAS MISSED 38 IN THE
26 --
>> WHY DON'T YOU THINK WHAT
CHUCK SAID IS ACCURATE?
>> I HAVE BEEN SAYING IT FOR
YEARS.
>> NO, NO, THEY HAVE KAWHI AND
PAUL GEORGE, THEY BECAME A
LEGITIMATE TEAM.
>> TRUE.
>> AND THEY MADE GREAT --
>> THEY HAD THE NORMAN POWELL
THING.
THREE GAMES --
>> WHEN THEY GET THE TWO BOYS
BACK --
>> YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE SOUNDED
GOOD?
>> WHAT?
>> ARE WE GOING GET CARMELO, WHO
WE GOING TO GET LeBRON, RUSS --
>> NO, WE SAID IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE SEASON, WE SAID -- ALMOST
SATE SAID IT.
>> THAT SET HIM UP.
>> WE SAID THAT TEAM FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WAS GOING TO
STINK BECAUSE THEY HAD ALL THE
OLD GEEDSERS THROUGHOUT, EXCEPT
IF ANTHONY DAVIS PLAYED MVP
BASKETBALL.
AND BEN GAY.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS?
>> IT'S THE ORIGINAL ICY HOT.
>> OKAY, MAN UP.
>> LET'S GET IN THE BREAK DOWNS.
>> I WILL GO QUICKLY.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT -- WE JUST
WATCHED A GAME.
WITH JA MORANT, A GUY WHO CAN
SCORE IN TRAFFIC.
WE TALK ABOUT LAKER PROBLEMS,
ONE OF THE LAKER PROBLEMS IS,
THESE ARE GUYS THAT CAN SCORE IN
SPACE BUT CANNOT SCORE IN
TRAFFIC OR WITH LACK OF SPACING.
FREEZE IT HERE.
WE HAVE MY MAN CUTTING THROUGH,
BUMPED THROUGH TWICE.
WE HAVE MONK ON THE BULL.
DWIGHT HOWARD, THERE'S ANOTHER
GUY NOT REALLY A SPACE SCORER.
HE NEEDS SPACE TO SCORE.
HE'S NOT REALLY SCORE IN
TRAFFIC.
THE PLAY RUNS THERE IS SO MUCH
EMPHASIS.
AND FREEZE IT ONE MORE TIME.
YOU HAVE ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR,
FIVE GUYS IN THE PAINT.
FIVE GUYS WHO ARE REALLY NOT
ABLE ON SCORE OR GET SEEN.
SO IF YOU DON'T SCORE IN
TRAFFIC, YOU CAN'T FIND THE GUYS
BACK HERE.
ACTIVE HANDS, ACTIVE READY.
GUYS THAT CAN SCORE IN TRAFFIC.
YOU CAN'T GET BACK.
WE CAN SCORE IN TRANSITION, YOU
GET A THREE IN YOUR HEAD, AND
FOR ME, ANTHONY DAVIS, HE SCORES
IN TRAFFIC, AND NOW, THE SHOOTER
ARE OVER, WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SCORING IN TRAFFIC --
>> CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
>> HE HAS TAPE.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> I HAVE TAPE.
>> MY FAVORITE MOVIE IS RUDY, I
WILL TELL YOU WHY.
>> RUDY --
>> RUDY PLAYED WITH A BUNCH OF
SUPERSTARS.
BUT HE CAME OUT AND PLAYED HARD.
RARELY TALKED ABOUT, I'M GOING
TO GO OUT AND DO MY JOB.
OPEN THREE, I WILL GET THE CROWD
IN THE GAME.
>> NO ONE IS LOOKING -- NO
LeBRON IN THE GAME.
>> YOU HAVE ALL THE SUPERSTARS,
AND I'M GOING TO PLAY HARD.
I WANT TO GIVE MAXIMUM EFFORT,
GET THE CROWD BACK IN THE GAME,
AND THEY SAID, WE WILL WIN THE
GAME BECAUSE OF RUDY.
>> THE ONE THING ABOUT THAT, AND
THE HIGHLIGHTS I WAS TRYING TO
EMPHASIZE IS WHEN LeBRON LEADS
THE GAME.
SECONDLY, THE GAME ISN'T PLAYED
IN FAST BREAKS IN THE FOURTH
QUARTER.
THEY CAN'T SCORE IN A HALF COURT
SET OR GUARD ANYTHING.
>> OR GUARD ANYTHING.
>> THAT GETS DOWN TO THE
STRETCH.
YOU PLAY HARD, AND LOSE BY SIX.
>> CAN I ASK YOU, DOES BRONNY
START OR COME OFF THE BENCH IF
HE COMES ON THE TEAM THIS YEAR.
>> WHO?
>> BRONNY?
UP.
>> BRONNY GOT A CHANCE TO START.
>> HE COULD START.
>> BRONNY, COME ON, WE NEED YOU.
>> THE CLIPPERS, 66-64.
THE CLIPPER BENCH OUTSCORING THE